♪ (intro music) ♪
Hello, everybody.
(applause)
My name is Mustafa.
Today I'll talk about high level APIs.
But I'll keep practitioners
like you in mind.
So to keep the practitioners in mind,
we'll define an example
where you can improve user happiness
by power of Mission Learning.
And after defining our example project,
we'll use Pre-made Estimators
to start our first experiment.
Then we'll experiment more
with every feature we have
by Feature columns and we'll introduce
a couple of Pre-made Estimators
that you can experiment more.
And we'll learn how can you experiment
other modeling ideas too.
So there are a lot of topics
we will cover in this talk.
And we'll also talk about
how can you scale it up
and serving so that you can use it
in your products.
Let's talk about the Estimators.
So it's a library that lets you focus
on your experiment.
There are thousands of engineers,
this is not a small number,
and hundreds of projects in Google
who use Estimators.
So we learn a lot from their experiments.
And we created our APIs
so that the time from an idea
to an experiment will be
as short as possible.
And I'm really happy to share
all these experience with all of you.
Whatever we are using internally
like Google
is the same as the open source one.
So you all have the same things.
Estimators keeps the model function.
We'll talk about
what's the model function later.
But it defines your network
and how can you train
or what is the behavior
during their evaluation
or during the export time.
And it provides you some loops
such as training, evaluation
and it provides you some interface
to integrate with TF Serving.
Also Estimators keep sessions
so that you don't need to learn
what is tf.Session.
It handles it for you.
But you need to provide data
and as Derek mentioned,
you can return a tf.Dataset
from your input function.
So let's define our project
and start with our experiment.
I love hiking, this is one of the pictures
I took in one of my hikes
and let's imagine there is a website,
hiking website similar to IMDB
but it's for hiking
and that website has information
for each hike
and users are labeling those hikes
by saying,
"I like this hike."
"I don't like this hike."
"This is my rating."
And other stuff.
And we want to use this data,
let's imagine you have this data
from that website
to recommend hikes for users.
How can we do that?
There are many ways of doing it.
Let's define one way
that Mission Learning can help us.
In this case, we want to predict
probability of a like,
whether a given user will like
a given hike or not.
What you have, you have hike features
and user features.
And where can you learn from?
You learn from the label data,
in this case, that website
has whether that users like
that hike or not.
So what can we use to predict
probability of a like?
You change one of the Pre-made Estimators
in this case the DNNClassifier
because this is a more strict edition
or you can think
it's a binary classification problem.
So with design Pre-made Estimators,
so that it can fit well
to this kind of problems,
this means you can use it
as a black box solution.
Pre-made estimators are surprisingly
popular within Google
and in many projects.
Why that many engineers are using
pre-made solutions
instead of building their own models?
I think first of all, it works.
It handles many implementation details
so you can focus on your experiment.
It has reasonable defaults
for initialization, partitioning,
or optimization
so that you have a reasonable baseline
as quick as possible.
And it is easy to experiment
with many features.
So we learn about that.
You can experiment with all of your data
by using the same estimators
without changing it.
So let's jump into our first experiment
so that we can have a baseline
that we will improve.
I will talk about embedded column
but in this case, let's--
you are using hike ID.
It may be a hike name
or an identification as a single feature
to your model.
And let's say you instantiate
the DNNClassifier
with hidden units one.
So what this will learn,
it will learn other each label
for each hike ideas
so that may be a good baseline
for your overall progress.
You need to say
what is your evaluation data,
what is your training data,
then you can code train and evaluate.
Just by these,
a couple of lines, of course,
you should be able to experiment
and you can see the results
on the task report.
For example you can see training
and evaluation loss
or how accuracy metric is moving.
So since this is a classification problem
you will see accuracy metric.
And since this is binary classification,
you will see
Area Under Curve for Precision-Recall.
So all of these things are free
and ready to be used.
Let's experiment more.
Let's start with the data,
experimenting with the data, itself.
The design feature columns
with the same mindset,
we want to keep--
make it easy to experiment
with your features, with your data.
And based on our experience,
internal experience,
it introduces the lines, of course
and may improve the model quality.
There are a bunch of transformations
you can handle via feature columns.
These are bucketing, crossing,
hashing, and embedding.
Each of these needs a careful explanation.
Unfortunately, I don't have
enough time here
but you can check Magnus' tutorial
and [Jess' media].
They are really good.
Let's experiment
with all the hike features we have.
Each hike may have tags
such as kid-friendly,
dog-friendly, birding.
You may choose indicator column
instead of embedding column in this case
because you don't have
a huge number of tags
so you don't need
to read this through dimensionality.
And for a numerical column,
such as each hike
may have elevation gain,
you need to normalize
so that optimization
will be well-conditioned,
your problem will be well-conditioned.
And you can use normalizer function here.
Or you may choose bucketizing,
in this case, the distance of a hike
we bucketize it
so that it will help the model
to learn different things
for different segments.
You can consider it
as a different kind of normalization too.
How can you use
all of these things together?
Just putting them into a list?
That's it, then your system
should work as it is.
So let's experiment with personalization.
What we mean by personalization
is instead of recommending
the same hikes to all users,
let's recommend different hikes
for different users
based on their interests.
And one way to do that
is using user features.
In this case, we are using user embedding
by embedding column.
So this will let the model to learn
a vector for each user
and put the users closer
if their hike preferences are similar.
And how can you use that?
Again, it's just depending into your list.
And you need to also play with
a number of hidden units
because you have many more features now
and you need to let your model
to learn different transformations.
And the rest of the pipeline should work.
You will hear this sentence a lot
during this talk
because it's based on that.
Rest of the pipeline should work
and you should be able
to analyze your experiments.
Let's experiment more.
We have a couple of pre-made solutions
I mentioned to you it's very popular.
And I picked on the two of them here
to show.
One of them is Wide-n-Deep.
It's a joint training of Neural model
and Neural Network.
It may have your product or it may not.
You need to experiment.
So let's start our the experiment.
You need to define what are the features
you want to feed to Neural Network.
Again, we have feature column,
here's the list.
And you need to define
what are the features
you need to feed into linear part.
In this case, I intentionally put user ID
and tags crossing so that,
for example, if a user always picks
dog-friendly hikes,
the model will explicitly learn
via this feature, via this cross.
And you can instantiate the
DNNLinearCombinedClassifier
instead of the DNNClassifier.
And the rest of the pipeline should work.
Based on the Kaggle survey,
2017 Kaggle survey,
trees are extremely popular.
And we are introducing
Gradient Boosted Trees
as a pre-made estimator.
This means you can experiment
with Neural Network
and Gradient Boosted Trees
without changing your pipeline.
Let's start with our experimentation
with Gradient Boosted Trees.
In the current version,
we only support bucketized column
and we are working on to support
numerical column
and categorical column too.
Here we use height distance
and high elevation gain
and we bucketize them
and then you can instantiate
BoostedTreesClassifier.
And the rest of the pipeline should work.
We know that trees are not
as computationally expensive as--
or training trees are not
as computationally expensive
as training Neural Networks.
And many of datasets fit into memory.
So by leveraging that,
we provide you a utility
so that you can train your model
more than an Order of Magnitude faster
than the usual one.
And the rest of the pipeline should work.
So let's say this already
pre-made solutions
are not enough for you
and you want to experiment more ideas.
Let's talk about that.
Before diving into this
high-level solutions that you can use,
let's look at the anatomy of the
Feedforward network
in a supervised setting.
In this case you have a network
which you'll fit the features
and based on the output of network
and the labels, you need to decide
what is the loss, what is the objective
you want to minimize
and what are the metrics
that you will use as a success metric
for your evaluation.
And your predictions on serving time
may be different than in training time
for example, if you have a large
multi-class setting,
you may want to use
just ranking of the classes
instead of the probabilities
in the serving time.
For that, you don't need
to calculate probability.
You can use the logistics
out of network to rank them.
So for all of this decisions,
we obstructed them out under Head API.
So Head API expects you to give the label
and out of your network
and provides all of these things for you.
We'll see in action.
And model function is an implementation
of this head and network together.
We'll talk about DNNClassifier.
So DNNClassifier has a model function,
so it's an implementation,
it's specifically an implementation
for head and network.
Let's implement this with the Head API,
in this case instead of DNNClassifier
we use DNNEstimator.
And we can instantiate ahead, in this case
it's a binary classification head
because we are trying to predict
whether it is liked or not liked.
And why are we introducing this head
since these two lines is the same
as DNNClassifier,
why are we introducing this head?
So that you can experiment many more ideas
by combining different
network architectures
and different heads.
For example, you can use Wide-n-Deep
with the Poisson regression head
or the DNNEstimator
with a multi-label head.
You can even combine
different heads together,
we introduce multi-head here.
So it's a one way of experimenting
with multi-task learning
with a couple of lines of code,
you can experiment
with multi-task learning.
Please check it out.
Let's say this pre-made architectures
are not enough for you
and you want to experiment more,
you can write your own model function.
We strongly recommend to use
TF Keras Layers
to build your network.
So you can do whatever you want,
you can be as creative as possible.
And after you have the output of network,
you need to pick one
of the optimizers available
in TensorFlow
and you can use one of the head
that we mentioned
which will convert your network output
and the labels
into training behavior
or evaluation metrics
or export behaviors.
Then you can fit this model function
to the estimator,
again, the rest of the pipeline
should work.
Keras Model is another way
of creating your model.
And it's very popular,
it's very intuitive to use.
For example, this is one
of the Keras Model you can build.
So how can you get the estimator
so that the rest
of the pipeline should work?
You can use model to estimators
which gives to the estimator
so you can run your experiments
without changing your pipeline.
Transfer Learning
is another popular technique
we do experiment with.
One way of extending is using model A
which is already the trend,
to improve the prediction of model B.
How can you do that?
Surprisingly, just copying
and transferring the variables
from model A to model B works.
That's simple but it works.
And we provide the utility for you.
You can use WARM start from--
For example this one line
is saying that transfer all of the model A
into model B
or you can define a subset of model A
to transfer from model A to model B.
Let's talk about image features,
we talked about embedding,
categorical column and numerical features
but what if you have image features?
How can you use them in your pipeline
without doing--
it will take up a lot of lines, of course.
You can implement one
of the state data image classifier
which is not a couple of lines, of course.
Or you can, thanks to TF-Hub,
you will learn a lot later,
you can use this one line,
just one line from the hub
to instantiate the features column
which is called
the image embedding column.
In this case, you may remember
Jeff mentioned OptiML.
NASNet is one of the OptiML model
and it's really good,
it's one of the state of the art model
you can use.
We will use NASNet as a featurizer
which means it will use only
the output layer of NASNet
as a feature in your pipeline.
How can you use that
in the DNNClassifier we talked about?
Same, you are just depending it
into your feature columns, done.
Then you can experiment it.
So let's say you experimented
and you find some models
but you need to scale it up,
not all of you but some of you
may need to scale your training.
So you can use multi-GPU
which means the application
on different GPUs,
Igor will talk about that after my talk,
the key point here
you don't need to change the estimator
or you don't need
to change the model code.
Everything should work
in just a single line
of configuration change.
Or you may want to distribute
your training to multiple missions
by saying these are workers,
these are parameter servers,
and there's one evaluator going on.
Same, you don't need to change
your estimator or model code.
Everything should work
based on the configuration.
Or you may want to use
TPUEstimator or TPU.
In this case, there's a minimal change
in the model function,
hopefully later we will fix that too
but now there's a minimal change
in your model function you need to do.
To use this in your production,
you need to export.
Or you can-- you need to serve.
And we recommend you to use TF Serving.
In the serving time, instead of reading
data from the files, you have a request.
And you need to define
the receiver function
which is defining how can you connect
that request into the model.
So in this case-- and after that
what will be the output of that model.
Which is defined by signature definition.
So here, again,
a couple of lines of code.
You will export your train model
with TF Serving [trend relay].
For example, if your request
is TF data example proto,
you can use this utility function
to get your receiver function.
And then you can use export said model
so that it will be used by TF Serving.
These are the modules I mentioned,
tf.estimator, feature column,
TF Keras, contrib.estimator,
contrib.feature column.
Please do not use tf.contrib.learn,
we are deprecating it.
And these are a couple of talks
and videos I picked.
You can check it out.
Thank you, I hope some of you
will improve your products
with the tools that we mentioned.
(greeting in foreign language)
(applause)
♪ (ending music) ♪